arguments in relationships are typically
so regrettable and often so bitter it's
natural to hope we might with greater
maturity overcome them
once and for all but given what human
nature is actually like it would be
unwise to make this our goal the hope
can't be to eliminate arguments
altogether it should be to try to find
our way to a better kind of argument
arguments tend to start when we confront
it usually rather suddenly
I would appears to us to be the radical
selfishness intransigence or sheer
nastiness of the partner it is extremely
tempting to react with equal force
we aren't after all a pushover we've
been hurt and we must hurt back we will
make them suffer as they have made us
suffer there may be variations in just
how we opt to inflict the suffering
perhaps we'll do a lot of shouting or
slam a door or maybe we'll eat this one
out with a sulk but the underlying
principle is the same
we've been hurt and we have to punish
but at this point we might ask ourselves
what we're really seeking after all
we're not trying to administer abstract
justice or punish for the sake of it
this isn't a criminal court or the
Headmaster's office what we're truly
seeking in a close relationship is
something much more touching we want the
other person to love us properly and to
be kinder that's why we're slamming the
door calling them a [ __ ] and have
been pretending they don't exist since
breakfast surprisingly almost the last
thing we ever do when we've been very
hurt is to say that we've been very hurt
it feels just too humiliating to reveal
our wound to the person who inflicted it
to show ourselves as vulnerable in front
of the very individual who it seems has
unbearably abused a vulnerability this
is both hugely understandable and
doesn't advance things in the least
because we're not in a relationship to
be emotionally safe we're there to find
connection an act of retribution while
it may give us a momentary impression of
impregnability never increases our
chances of obtaining the love and
understanding we formed a couple in
order to derive we might consider a
different and slightly paradoxical
approach we might exactly at the moment
when we've been wounded by our partner
instead of hitting back make what we
could term a dignified a vowel of hurt
and fear rather than get furious we
might attempt to register and get
directly at what is ailing us through a
two-fold admission we might say firstly
I'm so hurt that someone I've put my
emotional trust in should say or do that
to me and secondly and this takes proper
courage we might add I'm so frightened
that I should be emotionally deeply
exposed to someone who would appear to
hurt me like this this should give the
partner pause for thought one hasn't
insulted them or hurt them back in the
usual way which is what typically blocks
their ears and sets off a vicious cycle
of attack and counter-attack we are
being dignified and honest we are
lashing out but nor are we begging we
are neither being very strong nor very
weak where neither punching nor crawling
we're just standing still admitting on
genuine sadness fear and nakedness in a
tone of marked self-possession too often
arguments become interminable and to
outsiders
slightly daft because both people refuse
to admit that they're sad not mean it
isn't what time to leave for the airport
or whose turn it is to do the dishes
that's created the argument it's that
both parties are in different ways
feeling unloved and misunderstood but
refusing to say this in quite so many
words in a wider society with study
arguments at school for at least four
years there is complicated as algebra
and far more important and we'd all get
a lot better at confessing our wounds in
a tone of self-possessed dignity we'd
admit with calm that though were capable
and strong in most areas of our lives
here right now in the arena of the
relationship we are hurt and
and yet a brave and mature enough as
well as committed enough to love to dare
to tell the partner so in a plainest
mist undecorated and most heartfelt of
words we might thereby save ourselves a
lot of time we believe in making the
world a more emotionally intelligent
place and to that end we've now also
published some extraordinary books as
well as other merchandise that
reinforces some of the themes
illustrated in our videos please click
on the link below to see more